[Música]
no muy buenas noches para mí es un
placer estar con ustedes esta noche
para ponerles en contexto sobre como el
movimiento de la gente vive en honduras
ha venido avanzando en la reivindicación
de sus derechas y quiero remontar en los
años 80
para ese entonces los años 80s el
movimiento de la gente de honduras que
aglutinaba alrededor de los eventos
sociales o las fiestas las que permitían
que las personas lesbianas gays
bisexuales y trans olvidaron por un
momento la situación de discriminación
rechazo o violaciones de derechos
humanos que comenzaban en el seno
familiar ya en sus entornos sociales
debido a su orientación sexual o
identidad de género
estos eventos en sus inicios eran
realizados en lugares clandestinos o
casas particulares de las personas que
preparaban estas actividades sociales
para ese entonces entonces para ese
entonces no había problema alguno para
aquellos grupos conservadores que
históricamente han obstruido el avance
de los derechos en honduras ya que lo
que sucedía en estas actividades
sociales no trascendían las cuatro
paredes del lugar donde se realizaban
era como aquel proverbio que dice ojos
pozos que no ven corazón que no siente
sin embargo poco a poco los y las leyes
del movimiento de lgtb fueron tomando
valor y sacando con fuerza la cultura y
alegría de esta población lo que provocó
también que estos grupos adversos de
estos grupos conservadores sacaran con
mayor fuerza el odio y la discriminación
hacia todo aquel que se identificaba
como parte de este colectivo
esta situación de discriminación rechazo
y violaciones de derechos humanos hacia
la comunidad gay o por las personas
homosexuales como se le llamaba en la
década de los 80 en una una escalada un
aumento cuando aparece en honduras lo
que es la epidemia del vih
debido a que para ese entonces se creía
que solamente los homosexuales eran las
personas que podían contraer esta
infección y que eran los únicos que
podían propagar la a nivel nacional el
primer caso en honduras en 1985 de hecho
fue de una persona homosexual una
historia
un caso que ha venido formando parte de
la historia de la epidemia del vih en
honduras todo el mundo sabía escuchar
cuando hablan del tema de vih que una la
primera persona que el estado reconoce
como la primera persona viviendo con vih
es un homosexual un odontólogo del
progreso el progreso yoro entonces esa
situación se enmarca
en un aumento significativo de la
discriminación y la apología de odio
hacia las personas homosexuales esto
debido a que los grupos conservadores
utilizan este ambiente para poder
fomentar en la sociedad hondureña una
apología que contribuía a aumentar la
discriminación hacia las personas
homosexuales ya todo aquello que tenía
significado en el tema de los avances de
los derechos humanos de la comunidad
lgtb
para ese entonces será conocida como
sida
entonces
como tenía una afectación directa con la
comunidad lgtb se le denominaba con
diferentes términos peyorativos o
discriminativos que tenían una relación
directa con la población y homosexuales
como cáncer rosa y peste rosa está
refiriéndose con estos términos que
solamente a la comunidad homosexual
podría afectar y el resto de la sociedad
se sentía libre de esta efectiva de esta
infección sin embargo con el paso del
tiempo y con el avance de las
investigaciones se demuestra que el
virus del vih no tenía discriminación
alguna y por niños y por niñas y por
jóvenes ni por adultos y por mujeres ni
por hombres y por adultos mayores ni por
personas homosexuales y que todos y
todas estábamos expuestos a poder
infectar los de este virus
aunque estos avances demostraron o
desmintieron los mitos que habían
socavado los derechos de las personas
homosexuales y de la población lgp en
general el daño ya estaba hecho ya había
un crecimiento significativo en las
violaciones de derechos humanos y la
discriminación hacia las personas
homosexuales en la sociedad hondureña
había crecido a causa de esta situación
sin embargo la comunidad del eje tv con
las personas homosexuales como le decían
en aquel entonces no se queda de brazos
cruzados y comienzan a conformar grupos
de autoapoyo en los diferentes lugares
en donde el virus del vih o en donde la
población de la comunidad homosexual era
más afectada se conforme en ese entonces
la asociación hondureña de homosexuales
contra el sida un grupo que estaba
conformado de personas afectadas e
infectadas por este virus
que contribuirán a poder atender a las
personas homosexuales que estaban en los
centros hospitalarios en un quinto piso
o en salas retiradas del resto de
personas enfermas en los hospitales
porque lamentablemente
los prestadores de servicios de salud no
tenían información sobre este tema
tenían el temor y el miedo de poder
atender a estas personas porque creían
que solamente con tocar los que iban a
infectar
estos grupos de la comunidad de la gente
de estos los primeros que en el país
comienzan a trabajar el tema de
prevención del virus del vih y a tratar
de reducir mientras se estaba trabajando
en el tema de prevención la
discriminación que había aumentado y que
se había provocado por la aparición
este virus
en todo ese proceso el movimiento del
fpv han habido avances y estos avances
también al significados retrocesos que
han contribuido también en el tema de la
discriminación y violaciones de derechos
humanos hacia las personas homosexuales
o lg
cuando mencionó homosexuales es muy
interesante porque ya la comunidad del
getafe ha ido realizando un trabajo
fuerte en el tema de reivindicación de
los derechos humanos hoy en día los
nos gusta que la comunidad o la sociedad
en general sepa que nosotros somos parte
de la comunidad lgtb de este colectivo
que también está trabajando en el tema
de reivindicación de nuestros derechos
cuando una persona de la comunidad de la
gtb reconoce abiertamente que es
parte de este colectivo sufre de forma
cotidiana los embates de una sociedad
machista y de doble moral en muchos
casos estos embates comienzan en el seno
familiar donde las personas que son
parte de este colectivo de esta
población sufren de
maltratos físicos y psicológicos por
parte de sus padres
o por parte de su entorno social
y me hago una pregunta
qué culpa tiene un niño o un joven por
haber nacido con esta orientación sexual
también la traigo esta pregunta a mi
propia vida qué culpa tengo yo de haber
nacido gay
pero decidí vivir yo decidí venir a este
mundo con esta orientación sexual con
muchas de las preguntas que muchas de
las personas el eje tve se hace nuevo de
que estos golpistas por parte de su
familia o de sus hermanos o después de
que son corridos de sus hogares sólo por
creer ser diferentes al resto pero
diferentes a qué oa quién pues que a
casos todos los que estamos aquí somos
iguales pues que acaso no existe
diferentes formas de amar y de sentir
pues que acaso hasta las huellas
digitales de nuestras manos son
diferentes las unas de las otras
son preguntas que debemos de hacerlas y
analizarlas porque debemos de aprender a
respetar la diversidad que existe en
esta hondura que es de todos y de todas
en el tema de los avances del movimiento
de la gente de honduras puedo
mencionarles dos de los hitos históricos
que han marcado pasos significativos
para la reivindicación de los derechos
humanos
pueden ser pocos pero se han dado pasos
firmes en este trabajo desde las
organizaciones lgtb
hemos realizado a nivel nacional
el primero que se da es cuando el estado
de honduras reconoce el derecho que
tiene la comunidad del gtm de poder
asociarse o reunirse libremente esto a
través del otorgamiento de tres personas
jurídicas a las primeras tres
organizaciones lgtb el estado reconoce
que trabaja a nivel nacional para
defender los derechos de nuestra
comunidad sin embargo como bien lo decía
anterior anteriormente los avances
también han traído retrocesos a la
comunidad lgtb ese mismo año del 2004
luego del otorgamiento de las personas
jurídicas nuestros padres de la patria
pensaban que las organizaciones que en
ese momento habían adquirido la
personaría jurídica eran para promover
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo
es por ello en octubre de ese año se
introduce una moción al congreso
nacional para reformar dos artículos de
la constitución de la república el
artículo 112 y el artículo 116 el
artículo 112 que habla del matrimonio o
el derecho al matrimonio el artículo 116
que habla del derecho a la adopción
claras violaciones a los derechos
civiles y políticos de las personas lgtb
porque igual que ustedes igual que el
resto de ciudadanos y ciudadanas
hondureñas y hondureños nosotros también
tenemos derecho a una familia cuando se
violentan estos derechos entonces cuando
se cuando se reforman estos artículos se
violentan claramente estos preceptos
constitucionales como aquellos que están
descritos en el pacto internacional de
derechos civiles y políticos que
honduras ha suscrito así que no
solamente se han violado preceptos
constitucionales sino que también
honduras ha violentado a estos convenios
y tratados que en materia de derechos
humanos él mismo ha suscrito
el segundo que tenemos pero que lo
apague por acá
siguiente cortadora y tal vez me ayuda
este el segundo hito que se marca para
el movimiento elige tv
es cuando la situación sociopolítica que
se da el en junio del 2009 por esta
situación el movimiento ntv acude
autoconvocadas a las calles a poder
defender el estado de derecho que en ese
momento se había quebrantado en el país
esto permite el resto de movimientos
sociales históricos de honduras
reconozcan al movimiento del eje tíbet
como como un movimiento social más que
había nacido para reivindicar los
derechos de su población pero que
también había nacido para contribuir al
fortalecimiento de la democracia y al
fortalecimiento del estado de derecho
que en ese momento era necesario que los
ciudadanos y los y las ciudadanas sin
distinción alguna pudiéramos defenderlo
el cliente
sin embargo esta visibilización trae
consigo otras situaciones difíciles para
la comunidad lgtb
aunque este movimiento o este proceso o
esta coyuntura permite la visibilización
del trabajo
el movimiento realizada a nivel nacional
que las organizaciones lgtb realizaban
para reivindicaciones de estos derechos
trae consigo también el aumento de la
discriminación la apología del odio y
por ende más crímenes para la comunidad
lgtb
del 2009 hacia atrás se registraban
entre 7 y 12 personas el eje sería
asesinadas en el país del 2009 hasta la
fecha se han registrado más de 314
personas asesinadas en nuestro colectivo
un promedio de 31 personas elegiste de
asesinadas al año ustedes se preguntarán
bueno es una cifra no tan significativa
en 10 años 314 personas de la comunidad
lgtb en comparación a los 727 muertes
externas que se dan en el 2017 según el
observatorio de la violencia de la
universidad nacional autónoma de
honduras es una cifra
y no significativa podemos hacernos la
idea la situación se enmarca en la forma
en que una persona de la comunidad de
gtb asesinada pondría disparó sus
puñaladas amputados sus partes genitales
violaciones apedreados destruido sus
rostros con enormes piedras esta
situación enmarca la forma o el odio y
la distinta la discriminación que la
persona tiene al momento de quitarle la
vida a una persona de la comunidad lgtb
siguiente por favor
en el tema de la situación de los
defensores y defensoras de derechos
humanos es otro tema que también como
población del gtm nos preocupa ya que se
han asesinado a 11 defensores y
defensoras de los derechos humanos de la
comunidad lgtb
y esto no solamente preocupa a las
organizaciones que nos dedicamos a esta
labor también organismos internacionales
han solicitado al país que mejore la
situación
y el trabajo que los y las defensoras
realizan en honduras porque es necesario
que existan personas que existamos
personas que contribuyan a poder
defender y promover los derechos y no
solamente de la comunidad lgtb
a los derechos humanos de todos y de
todas
es por ello
el avance de los derechos humanos ha
sido significativo y progresivo a lo
largo de la historia ha evolucionado
poco a poco pero esto es debido a que
han existido personas quedaron puestos
sus vidas al servicio de esta noble
labor que han sacrificado su tiempo y su
espacio para poder reivindicar los
derechos humanos de todos y de todas
hoy que ustedes me están escuchando en
este momento se preguntarán pero cómo
podemos ser defensores o quién puede ser
defensor o defensora de derechos humanos
todos los que estamos aquí podemos
convertirnos en defensores y defensoras
de derechos humanos no importa la edad
no importa el sexo el género la
orientación sexual la identidad dije la
identidad de género
recordemos primero que todos
pertenecemos a la raza humana y por
pertenecer a la raza humana no podemos
permitir que en nuestro país continúen
vulnerando los derechos de todos y de
todas
como lo dijo el cliente por favor
voy a salir más para cabeza
3 me ayuda ahí por favor y como lo dijo
en una de sus frases célebres nelson
mandela
privar a las personas de sus derechos es
poner en tela de juicio su propia
humanidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]